there seems to be a ton of regulatory
pressure uh both from actual regulators
uh and also what i'll call more of kind
of politicians or people who are elected
officials uh maybe let's just start with
how you view regulation obviously as a
public company ceo you're regulated by a
ton of different organizations there's
all these different rules um
like how do you view the regulation and
is there a thing as like good regulation
bad regulation or how do you look at
this yeah so this is a very interesting
dynamic that's happening recently but
honestly it's been happening for the
entire time that coinbase has been
around nine nine years or so um it's
just kind of the intensity keeps dialing
up every year because crypto keeps
getting bigger and bigger and so
generally i view this all as a very
positive trend
um you know in the early days of
coinbase we made a conscious decision we
said hey we want to go out there and
work proactively with regulators and
educate them get licenses
do whatever we need to do because we
want this technology to go mainstream i
want there i want there to be a billion
people accessing an open financial
system every day through the through our
products and other other companies to
get the benefit of this technology and i
knew that
you know in in most parts of the free
world this was not going to be outlawed
or something like that at least i didn't
think that was very likely but it would
be regulated i i felt like you know
society is is not going to just allow
this to proliferate completely
unregulated so over time we went and we
got money transmitted licenses and we
started interfacing with um all of the
federal leg regulators and actually
today coinbase um interfaces interacts
with 54 different regulators just in the
united states and we're actually in um
you know about 30 or 40 countries
globally and so we're very much a global
company so we interface with similar
counterparts um in other places so
where is this all going i mean
for a long time the crypto industry i
think has been asking for
uh clarity from the regulators out there
and saying
you know this is also new and now i
don't blame the regulators by the way
for not coming out with a ton of clarity
quickly it's such a brand new thing it
actually might have been a mistake to
come out out with it too quickly because
there are examples historically probably
of uh regulation that's come out it's
like kind of overreacted or tried to
find something too soon and this space
is evolving so quickly
so you know they kind of let it um they
kind of let it percolate we sort of
shoehorned the regulation into the
existing frameworks that are out there
like like money transmission um but now
with the advent of all this stuff the
government is starting to get more
pressure and say hey what are we going
to do about this and so you're seeing
this kind of dance that's happening a
little bit of healthy tension i would
call it
between the regulators now who are
coming out and saying all right y'all we
need to get this figured out
what's unfortunate sometimes they're
kind of doing that through enforcement
actions which um i don't think is
necessarily fair if they haven't kind of
already just
you know picked up the phone and said
hey here's our opinion on this like we
want to enforce a level playing field
across the industry everybody do this
i haven't seen that happen in some cases
which is a little frustrating they're
kind of going right to enforcement which
i think sort of sets up a negative tone
um but regardless it doesn't really
matter if it happens via enforcement or
um more internal dialogue and everything
like that we'll eventually get to a
place where we start to create legal
precedence um more of this stuff becomes
clear and the court may end up having to
eventually decide on some of these
things like which of these tokens are
securities you know um in the absence of
clarity about that topic i mean we have
we have the howie test right but the
howie test was created back in 1946
um in a world pre-internet you know pre
it was like post right after world war
ii right so how could this howie test
apply to this brand new financial system
we're creating basically every founder
and investor and um
their highly paid lawyers are all kind
of trying to tease out like read the tea
leaves about what this could possibly
mean for their business and it's created
this kind of wide variety of
interpretations and a completely
ambiguous environment which kind of
stifles um startups and some of those
startups have decided to go abroad in to
incorporate because of the lack of
clarity in the u.s so now we're sitting
here in this environment
where um you know in the absence of that
clarity coinbase went out and sort of we
created things like the crypto rating
council we created a very thorough um
digital asset listing process internally
that looked at compliance and legal and
security cyber security and we were
actually pretty cautious about a lot of
the assets we added
um you know at the time that coinbase
had maybe 50 assets or so there was
uh some of our competitors had hundreds
of them right and now we have about 100
assets total that we've gotten
comfortable with many of them other ones
we've rejected and so i would expect um
this whole environment is just over the
next year or so it's going to be
a series of enforcement actions a series
of behind closed door discussions legal
precedent getting created um there will
probably be broker dealer licenses
incorporated um or i should say
operationalized you know coinbase went
out and got its brokerage license a
while back but we haven't
operationalized it because there aren't
any security tokens that our customers
want to to actually trade and so maybe
once we get that operational then other
crypto tokens will then go be pushed to
register with the sec
we actually want to make that easy as
well through a product we have called
coinbase asset hub and just make it
super simple for any asset issuer to
come you know
form a smart smart contract or however
they want to do it create a new a new
asset register it with
the sec if they need to do that in the
us do a reg s offering if they want to
do it abroad
so we want to try to make all this
easier
more regulated i think we're all pretty
much aligned even the regulators and and
the industry there's just going to be a
bunch of
silly headlines and you know
uncomfortable conversations as that all
plays out
so i i want to try to kind of summarize
what i believe to be ural's position but
if i misspeak uh correct me is basically
look we want to play within the rules we
think regulation is generally good uh
but in some areas we don't know what the
rules are and so we're trying our best
but if we don't know what those rules
are and then all of a sudden we get told
hey don't do that it's kind of hard to
operate a business with uncertainty uh
it feels like that's one kind of talk
track or uh um you know viewpoint
another is hey there's things that we
think should be allowed that feels like
the regulators are telling us they
aren't allowed and we want to have a
discussion and maybe there isn't a
discussion at the level that you want to
have it or uh you're not getting
guidance that you're looking for etc and
then there's like this third world which
is basically like hey we do things as a
publicly traded company in a regulated
environment in the united states but
like look globally and there's people
doing all kinds of different things and
so there's like a global competition
going on how much does the us want to
over regulate or regulate versus like
wide open free markets and just let
everyone go let the free market decide
is that kind of a fair characterization
of like maybe like the three points
around regulation and where you sit
that's a really great articulation of it
yeah i do think that's really important
to remember as well the last point you
said which is that we are living in a
globally
a global free market right you know us
citizens actually
are going and using products that are
created abroad um increasingly because
they're not able to get the stuff they
want in the u.s so that's a risk
you know i think the us government um
again we're a global company i talk to
regulators all of the world but one
thing i noticed when i go to dc
is that i think
you know 50 percent of the people i talk
to in dc roughly they're still thinking
of crypto as a risk they think this is
scary this is dangerous they have all
kinds of misconceptions in their head
about
the percentage of activity that's for
illicit activist purposes and all this
which it's actually much smaller than
most of them realize it's probably about
one percent or less whereas the us
dollar cash is like three to four
percent illicit activity right but in
their mind they think it's like 50
illicit activity so that's probably half
the people i meet in dc
and the other half are they realize that
this is actually a huge opportunity it's
a huge really important new industry for
the united states and every country
around the world and that they exist in
a competitive environment where the us
needs to be attracting these
entrepreneurs getting these foundational
companies built here and that frankly
you know the american citizens really
want these products and services uh tens
of millions of americans this is not a
fringe thing anymore you know coinbase
has 60 million verified users you know
um and we're just one company so there's
there's tens of millions of americans
who want to use these products and
services
they're getting a benefit from it that
they're not getting from the traditional
financial system and ultimately you know
the citizens elect our government and
the government appoints regulators and
everything like that and so
i think that if if they are too hard on
crypto basically it's going to become
politically infeasible they're not going
to have um the will of the people behind
that it's almost like um
prohibition or something like that
historically like you can't
you can't go out and like try to
criminalize something that um you know
50 million americans are doing uh you're
just gonna turn them all into criminals
but they're not gonna stop doing it and
so i think that's the maybe the one of
the big things that hasn't been um
realized yet on in dc
so what's up guys bang bang thanks so
much for watching the best business show
today if we're gonna be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you ten dollars in bitcoin for free it's
that simple head on over to sofi.com to
get started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more of the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]